how do you keep the audience engaged
in the script you keep them engaged by
making them work you know they they're
they're a
an observer of the movie and you're
leading him along the path but like
billy wilder said you give an audience
you you allow an audience to add up two
plus two
equals four they're going to love you
forever right so
we want to watch a movie but we also
want to
oh you know yeah that you know setups
payoffs i had this discussion
recently with another writer goes well i
don't
write a lot of those you know setups and
stuff like the commercial movies you
write
i was like okay um but
setups we love that you know because in
act one when we set up this thing
it saves in act two we go that's the i
wondered why they showed the
the keys in the thing right everything's
for a reason
nothing in there is is left to chance
you know what i mean
um so you keep an audience engaged by
interesting characters too
you know so a setup
is a little clue yeah setups and
sometimes the setup is not paid off you
know there's there's films
many times maybe like in a noir or
something you go you thought was gonna
and it doesn't you're like that's okay
but
when you when you have little setups
that that later on
you know oh my gosh um that's why he
left the knife in the thing because he
thought
you know and so when you get that you're
now being you're active
in your mind not just passive watching a
movie go by
you know it becomes more interesting you
know
um i don't know just
so clues but some of them can be false
sure
to keep the fuel on their toes and um
twists and turns are extremely important
we don't want to just go ah
you know the minute you you bring us
along and think we're going one way we
zag on another
you know that that's going to keep my
interest you know well yeah
where it's not just i've seen this
before you know what's gonna happen
the killer's gonna be behind the door
lift the thing and then when that
doesn't happen you're like oh
you know it didn't wow it's different
it's refreshing you know
rather than like a formulaic cookie
cutter
i've seen this a million times before
which happens
you know or also the the
benevolent nature of the character like
you think somebody is
right in their camp sure yeah characters
as well
uh changing sides and allegiance and
you know all that stuff is that's why um
you have to have it all throughout to
make it interesting to make us
want to or in a screenplay want to turn
that page
for like uh you know i want to have a
page turner
just like that's the way the movie's
going to be hopefully a page turner you
know
i can't wait to the next scene you know
um cliffhangers
you know it's a tv show cliffhanger we
end up this episode
they come at the end of the cliff you
know they're gonna go
in the next oh you caught my no they got
saved you know
um or especially like in
films where everybody seems dark in
terms of their motives
but actually you find out like i'm
thinking of margin call it was great
great did you watch martial no you
didn't see that okay yeah it was about
um well we'll skip it it's good but
everybody seems
except for stanley tucci's character but
most people there you're like
all of the characters their motives seem
you know this is during the recession
and you're not sure who's going to lose
their job
right right who's kind of quote selling
out and
uh yeah just it keeps you on your toes
because you're not sure
yeah that that definitely keep an
audience watching you know
look at some of the like i say some of
the best films um
and and look at those and say how did
that work you know
um and again characters too we want to
go on the ride
where we like these characters that's
another thing too when i read the script
i'm like
we want to care about them it's another
thing when i read a script i'm like
i don't really care about just because
they're here on the page
right yeah you know i want to i want to
root for them
you know or or be surprised or you know
something some kind of emotional
response let's say glenn gary glenn ross
yeah so not all of the characters in
fact many of them were not likeable sure
but there was something in them like to
say jack lemmon's character yeah
you cared about him right you saw the
desperation and you wanted
you were you know there would be
they weren't maybe necessarily people
you'd want to work with yeah there was
something in them
that you cared for yeah that's hard to
craft i mean
absolutely
you